[موسيقى]
العائدون من داعش حكايه تحتل اليوم
الصداره في المجتمعات الغربيه وتحديدا
الاوروبيه تتلخص في الاجراءات الامنيه
لمواجهه مخاطر العائدين من العراق وسوريا
ومحاسبه المتورطين او المشاركين في جرائم
حرب وقعت في كل من سوريا والعراق لكن
المحاكمات في عدد من الدول الاوروبيه
وبريطانيا كشفت الستار عن ملف جديد ومثير
وهو جواسيس داعش او العملاء المزدوجين
مؤخرا برزت قضيه احمد سمسم الذي كان يقاتل
في صفوف تنظيم داعش بحسب المحاكم
الاسبانيه الا انه وفقا لاعترافات احمد
سمسم ادنماركي من اصول سوريا فانه كان
يعمل سرا لصالح اجهزه الاستخبارات او
التجسس الدنماركيه التي تخلت عنه كما ذكر
هناك ايضا قصه العميل المزدوج في اجهزه
المخابرات الكنديه محمد الراشد المتورد في
قضيه تهريب الفتاه البريطانيه شميمه بيجو
عروس داعش برفقه اثنتين من صديقاتها من
بريطانيا الى سوريا في العام 2015
بالاضافه الى دوره في تجنيد وتسفير عشرات
المقاتلين الاجانب للانضمام لتنظيم داعش
حكايه استقطاب وكالات الاستخبارات
العالميه لجواسيس مزدوجين في قلب هذه
التنظيمات لا تقتصر على تنظيم داعش بل
ايضا كان صداعا فتك بتنظيم القاعده ونذكر
منه العميل الدنماركي المزدوج مارتن ستور
الذي كان جهاديا ثم انقلب واصبح عميل
استخباراتيا في قلب تنظيم القاعده مساهما
في تصفيه القياده اليمني انور العولقي
بالاضافه الى العميل رمزي الذي اخترق
تنظيم القاعده في افغانستان والبوسنه
والشيشان وبالعوده الى تنظيم داعش كانت
الضربات التي استهدفت مواقع التنظيم
وقيادات الصف الاول كفيله بان تصيب
التنظيم بالهوس او البارانويا حيث امر
باعدام وقطع رؤوس عناصره وقياديه حتى
لمجرد الشك وكانت تنظيم قد شكل وحده
استخباراتيه سريه مسؤوله عن صيد الجواسيس
مقدما ما يقارب 5000 دولار مقابل كل جاسوس
يتم القبض عليه
وسقط تنظيم داعش ذلك في تسجيلات مختلفه
منها تسجيل مرئي نشر في العام 2015 يظهر
فيه التنظيم اعدام 14 جاسوسا باحراقهم
واغراقهم وتفجير رؤوسهم واصدار اخر بعنوان
حصاد الجواسيس اليوم في اوروبا اصبحت
عباره جواسيس داعش تاتي اجابه سريعه على
كل من تساءل عن سبب رفاهيه التنقل والعمل
باريحيه لمقاتلين سابقين شوهدت مقاطعهم
بين صفوف التنظيم او نساء عملنا في كتيبه
الخنساء كام حمزه ولكن هذه المره باسماء
وعناوين جديده وسريه فما القواعد
الاخلاقيه في اطار العملاء المزدوجين في
داخل التنظيمات الارهابيه وما المبادئ
التي يستوجب اعتمادها من قبل وكالات
الاستخبارات العالميه وكيف يتحول الجهاد
الى عميل مزدوج انا هدى الصالح وهذا
برنامج جماعات ارحب بضيفنا المح والوزير
السابق الاستاذ محمود الخرابشه وهو الضابط
السابق في المخابرات العامه الاردنيه حياك
الله معنا سعاده العميل اهلا فيك يا مرحبا
طبعا احنا نعرف سعاده العميد موضوع
الجواسيس او العملاء المزدوجين دائما هو
موضوع مثير وشيق خاصه انه دائما بيحصد
اعلى المشاهدات في صناعه الافلام العالميه
لكن اليوم حديثنا على ارض الواقع ما مدى
اهتمام وكالات الاستخبارات العالميه
والدوليه في اختراق التنظيمات الاصوليه
الراديكاليه المسلحه
شكرا ستي يعني الحقيقه هذا احد اهم مواضيع
وواجبات وكالات المخابرات في كل دول
العالم باعتبار انه الحرب الان اصبحت حرب
مخابرات وحرب معلومات
لذلك كل وكالات المخابرات واجهزه
المخابرات واجهزه الامن في كل دول العالم
تحاول ان تخترق كل التنظيمات التي تعتقد
انها تعمل ضدها وضدها منها وضد امن
واستقرار بلادها بالاضافه الى ان كثير من
الاجهزه المخابرات ووكالات المخابرات
تحاول ايضا ان تخترق التنظيمات الكبيره
التي لها وجود ولها قدره على القيام
بعمليات ارهابيه وعمليات تخريبيه على
امتداد مساحات العالم
واصبحت اجهزه المخابرات ايضا
تقوم بتنسيق
معلوماتها وتبادل المعلومات ضمن الحدود
التي يسمح بها طبعا
المجال حتى لا يتم التاثير على امن هذه
المعلومات وامن المصادر لذلك استطيع ان
اقول ان
الاهتمامات في في كبد تنظيمات الارهابيه
من على امتداد مساحات العالم تحظى باهتمام
كبير من اجهزه المخابرات في كل دول العالم
وهنالك كما قلت ايضا تعاون وتنسيق مشترك
بين كثير من اجهزه
الاجهزه الامن واجهزه الاستخبارات
والمخابرات لكي يتم تبادل المعلومات ويتم
ايضا الحصول على المعلومات باعتبار ان
المعلومات يعني تهم كافه اجهزه الامن
للحفاظ على امنها وللمنع الارهابيين
والذين يقومون ببعض العمليات من الوصول
الى الاخلال بالامن والاستقرار لان هذه
المعلومات تشكل عامل اساسي ورئيسي لكبح
جماع هذه التنظيمات ومنعها من زعزعه الامن
استقرار في كثير من دول العالم وانت
تعلمين انه يوميا لازلنا حتى الان نلاحظ
ان هنالك الكثير من العمليات التي تستهدف
امن واستقرار كثير من دول العالم طيب ساده
العميد ابي اسالك ايش انواع الجواسيس او
انواع العملاء اللي دائما يعني ما بيتعاون
او يحاول ان يجندهم
او تجندهم وكاله الاستخبارات يعني وكالات
الاستخبارات تسعى لتجنيد العملاء المتصلين
بالاهداف التي يعملون من اجلها وبالتالي
اذا اذا تيسر لهم تجنيد هؤلاء الاشخاص
الذين يعملون من داخل هذه التنظيمات هذا
يكون عاده صيد ثمين ويكون له وضعه لكن
ايضا على الجانب الاخر
هنالك محاولات لزرع بعض الاعضاء داخل هذه
التنظيمات وبعض الجواسيس داخل هذه
التنظيمات بهدف ايضا ان يكون هنالك قدره
الحصول على المعلومات
المطلوبه بالوقت المناسب وقبل ان يفوت
الاوان لذلك اجهزه الامن في العالم كما
قلت تحاول ان تجند اشخاص من داخل هذه
التنظيمات وممن يعملون فيها او ممن لهم
علاقات مع هذه التنظيمات او يقومون بصراعه
بعض العناصر داخل هذه التنظيمات لكي يكون
على اتصال
بالتنظيم لانه اي شخص اذا لم يكن على
اتصال مباشر
بالتنظيم الارهابي
ويحصل على المعلومات بالوقت المناسب لا
يحقق الهدف الذي من اجله يتم التعامل مع
هؤلاء العملاء وهؤلاء الجواسيس سادس احنا
نعرف ان حرب المعلومات هي مهمه في يعني
ضمان حمايه الامن الامن القومي لكن لابد
ان هناك قواعد ومبادئ في عمليه تجنيد
العملاء المزدوجين احنا بنتكلم عن في داخل
تنظيمات المسلحه من تتبنى من كانت تتبنى
الفكر الاصول ثم ابدت استعدادها بان تكون
اصول استخباراتيه بالتزويد المعلومات يعني
الاجهزه الامن واجهزه الاستخبارات
والمخابرات في العالم كما قلت تسعى لكي
يتم تجنيد اشخاص لهم اتصال مباشر مع هذه
التنظيمات
وتجنيد اشخاص من قلب هذه التنظيمات وخاصه
اذا كانوا على اطلاع باهدافها وبعملياتها
او كانت لديهم معلومات لكن هذا قد لا يكون
سهلا الا اذا كان هنالك ظروف مواتيه ادت
الى تجنيد هؤلاء الاشخاص من داخل هذه
التنظيمات لكن على الجانب الاخر كما قلت
اجهزه الامن تعمل بالاتجاه الاخر وهو
محاوله زرع بعض الاشخاص وبعض العناصر داخل
هذه التنظيمات وترعاها وتدعمها حتى يكون
لا اهلها من شانها في المستقبل الحقيقه
اجهزه الامن تحاول ان تجمع معلومات دائما
وباستمرار عن كافه الاشخاص الذين لهم
علاقه بهذه التنظيمات وتحاول ان تصل اليهم
بكافه الطرق والوسائل انا اسالك عن
القواعد والمبادئ يعني هل هناك عند اختيار
العميل المزدوج لاني انا ابيت خلفيه صلب
موضوعنا اللي هم جواسيس داعش هل هناك
معايير معينه مدى انخراط هذا العنصر في
داخل التنظيم هل هو متورط في اعمال او
مشارك في الاعمال في اعمال التنظيم نفسها
ام ان يعني بيكون لابد ان يكون لم يصل الى
مرحله الانخراط في الاعمال الجرميه لا
يعني هي الحقيقه العمليه قد تكون على
درجات وعلى مستويات اذا كان هنالك امكانيه
لتجنيد العملاء والاشخاص المنخرطين
والمتصلين في هذه التنظيمات شريطه ان يتم
التاكد من مصداقيتهم وان يتم اختبارهم وان
يكون هنالك عوامل لدراسه نفسياتهم ودراسه
مدى مصداقيتهم وجديدهم بالتعامل هذا يكون
يعني كم له له
اثار كبيره جدا للحصول على المعلومات ايضا
اذا تم وقوع بعض العناصر بين يدي الى
الاجهزه الامنيه لسبب او لاخر وكان هنالك
معلومات عن هؤلاء العناصر يتم تجنيدهم
وتدريبهم وتاهيلهم ويتم متابعتهم ايضا
وسرعهم بداخل هذه هم اهداف لاجهزه الامن
اذا كان لديهم اتصالات مع هذه التنظيمات
واذا كان لديهم معلومات ايضا عن هذه
التنظيمات
وهؤلاء يشكلون صيد ثمين للاجهزه
الاستخبارات واجهزه المخابرات للوصول
لهؤلاء الاشخاص وتجنيدهم هذا من ناحيه
ثانيه ايضا اجهزه الامن والاستخبارات تح
ان تستغل وجود بعض الماخذ الامنيه على بعض
الاشخاص ممن لهم علاقه بهذه التنظيمات
وتحاول ان تدخل من نقاط الضعف هذه وتقوم
بتجنيد هم شريطك التاكد من ولائهم والتاكد
من مصداقيتهم والتاكد من رغبتهم بالعمل
والانتاج ايضا اجهزه كما قلت تستطيع ان
ترسل بعض الاشخاص بعد تجنيدهم وبعد
دراستهم ودراسه ثقافتهم وامكانياتهم واذا
كانوا قادرين على ان يصلوا الى هذه
الاهداف او الى هذه التنظيمات وان ينغرسوا
بهذه التنظيمات وبالتالي يصل الى مراكز
صناعه القرار والحصول على المعلومات لذلك
اجهزه الامن هي حاله من الصراع الخفي بين
اجهزه الامن وبين هذه التنظيمات والان كما
اشرت بالمقدمه اللي حضرتك تفضلتي فيها عدد
كثير من هؤلاء عادوا الى
دولهم او عادوا الى بلدانهم اللي يحملوا
جنسياتها وهؤلاء لا بد من التعامل معهم
بحذر باعتبار انهم قد يكون غير موثوقين
وقد يكون عادوا لكي يقوموا ببعض المهام
المطلوبه منهم امنيا لصالح هذه التنظيمات
لذلك هذا بحاجه الى متابعه بحاجه الى
دراسه بحاجه ايضا الى ان يكونوا تحت
المراقبه الدائمه باستمرار حتى يتم التاكد
من نواياه ممكن ان يلعب على الطرفين يعني
يكون يبيع معلومات لجهاز مخابرات وبنفس
الوقت يبيع معلومات اخرى لتنظيم نفسه نعم
صحيح وقد يكون لديه بعض المهام الموكل
بيها بان يقوم بتنفيذها داخل البلاد من
خلال الاستمرار تعاونه علاقته مع تنظيم
الارهابي وايضا كما قلتي واشرت ان بعضهم
اصبح تجار معلومات واصبحت تنظيمات
الارهابيه ايضا لديها قدره على ان تتعامل
مع الاجهزه الامنيه والاجهزه الاستخبار
الاستخباراتيه لانه عملهم كله ينحصر ضمن
هذا الاطار وضمن هذا الجانب وينحصر ضمن
الاطر السريه التي يجب ان يحافظ عليها في
سبيل القيام بمهامه وواجباته ولذلك
الحقيقه العمل شارك وصعب طب سعاده العميد
ابغى ادخل معاك من هذه النقطه الى تصريح
جاستين ورئيس وزراء كندا بعد اعتقال احمد
الراشد العميل المزدوج في اجهزه
الاستخبارات الكنديه وكان اعتقالها في
تركيا لدوره في تهريب الفتيات المراهقات
البريطانيات واللي عرفوا بانهم تحت وصف
عرائس داعش
بالاضافه الى تجنيد او نقل العشرات الى
داخل التنظيم خلال عمله مع الجهاز
الاستخبارات وقال ان على جهاز الاستخبارات
انه التحلي بالمرونه والحس الخلاق في
ناجحه بالمقابل كان هناك شجب من قبل
منظمات حقوقيه غربيه للدور للعبه جهاز
الاستخبارات الكندي في هذه الحاله على
سبيل المثال بان من ان يكون حليف يحمي
المواطنين عوضا عن الاتجار بالاطفال
والمراهقين في منطقه الحرب وان جمع
المعلومات قد حظي بالاولويه على حساب
الاطفال فايش رايك بهذا الحديث من واقع
عملك
وخبرتك في جهاز المخابرات يعني الحقيقه
هذه حاله نادره ما تتحدثين عنه قد لا يحصل
لدى جميع اجهزه الامن في العالم كثير من
الاجهزه الامنيه في العالم الحقيقه تحافظ
على مستويات بغض النظر عن كل ما يقال
تحافظ على مستوى من الاخلاقيات والمثل في
التعامل وقيامها بمهامها وواجباتها عمليه
تنظيمات تنظيم داعش وتهريب الفتيات
القاصرات الحقيقه هذا عمل مستهجا ومستنكر
لانه لا يجوز باي حال من الاحوال ان يتم
المتاجره بالبشر وهنالك قانون يجرب
المتاجره بالبشر لكننا نتحدث عن تنظ
[موسيقى]
ما يسمى
بكثير من الاحيان والخروج على القواعد
الاخلاقيه والخروج على القواعد الدينيه
لكن الحقيقه لك كثير من اجهزه الامن في
العالم تتمسك بمبادئ ولا تخرج عن قوانين
والانظمه التي يتم التعامل معها لذلك انا
اقول انه اجهزه الامن هي جزء من الدوله
وجزء من كيانها وجزء من ثقافتها القانونيه
لا يجوز ان يتم الخروج او ان يسمح بالخروج
على ما يشير الى كرامه الانسان او يمتهن
كرامه الانسان خاصه مثل هذه الحاله التي
ذكرتها حضرتك في حاله تعامل مع عرائس داعش
او ما يتعلق بالفتيات والقصه لان هؤلاء
بحاجه الى حمايهم ودور اجهزه الامن في
العالم ان تحمي مثل هذه الفئه من
المواطنين القصر والا تسمح باي حال من
الاحوال ان يتم المتاجره بهم حتى وان كان
العميل المزدوج ان يعني يقنع يقنع العميل
المزدوج الاجهزه الاستخبارات بانه هو
يشارك في هذه الاعمال من باب بث المصداقيه
او يعني القنت التنظيم بانه جزء منها فقد
يمارس القتل او يشارك في القتل ويشارك في
التعذيب يعني درء الشبهات عن نفسها هذا ما
بيكون يعني
كعذر له او يعتبر يعني خرق لقواعد اخلاقيه
في جهاز اجهزه المخابرات يعني اسمحي لي
الحقيقه انا انا اقول بان اجهزه المخابرات
لديها مثل ايضا ولا يمكن لها باي حال من
الاحوال ان تخرج على القوانين او ان تقوم
باعمال مجرمه وممنوعا قانونيا سواء كان
ضمن القانون الوطني او ضمن القانون الدولي
في هنالك حاله حقوق الانسان وهنالك العهد
الدولي للحقوق الانسان وهنالك ايضا قوانين
وانظمه يجب ان يتم الانسان بها لكن بعض
الاجهزه تخرج على هذه القاعده احيانا اذا
كانت مصلحتها وامنها واستقرارها واستقرار
وطنها في خطر لكن بالنتيجه هذه لا يمكن ان
يقاس عليها ولا يمكن ان تكون مثال يمكن
لاجهزه الامن في العالم ان تسير على هذا
المنوال لانه كما قلت صحيح نحن نعلم ان
الاجهزه الاستخباراتيه والامنيه معنيه
بتحقيق الامن ومعنيه ايضا بتحقيق
الاستقرار ومعنيه بالوصول الى المعلومات
بالوقت المناسب من خلال هذه التنظيمات
الارهابيه وان هذه التنظيمات الارهابيه
سواء كانت محليا او اقليميا او دوليا هي
مجال عمل اجهزه في الامن واجهزه الامن
تسعى جاهدا للحصول على المعلومات باي حال
من الاحوال اسمح لي اسالك في هناك ايضا
يعني في حالات كثيره في اوروبا بدات يعني
تثير الريبه عند
المهاجرين او اللاجئين السوريين انفسهم
حيث انك شخصيات كثيره هم شاهدوا صورهم
شاهدوا مقاطع لهم من يحمل رؤوس مقطوعه
ايضا هناك نساء شاركوا في كتيبه الخنساء
منهم ام حمزه هي موجوده اليوم في السويد
تتنقل بحريه وهي شاركت في تجنيد فتيات
ومعروفه لدى كثير من النساء السوريات
المتواجدين ايضا في السويد ولا زالت لديها
علاقاتها في داخل هذه التنظيم في هذا داخل
هذا التنظيم
يعني هنا انا صراحه يشكل عليش البعد
الاخلاقي في هذا الموضوع يعني الجهاز
المخابرات عندما يجند عملاء مزدوجين هل
يعني
بيضع هذه في عين الاعتبار هذا النقطه مثلا
السوابق الذي التي ارتكبها العميل المزدوج
الارهابيه التي تستبيح الارواح والاعراض
والممت لا يوجد لديها مثل ولا يوجد لديها
اخلاق لان هذه التنظيمات ارهابيه ليست دول
لكن الاجهزه الامن اجهزه تعمل في اطار دول
وتعمل ضمن اطر قانونيه واطرش دستوريه
وبالتالي لا يجوز لها ان تضرب عرض الحائط
بهذه القوانين وهذه الانظمه وان تتعامل مع
هذه التنظيمات بما يمكنها من السيطره على
هذه التنظيمات وكبح جماحها ومنعها لتنفيذ
ايه عمليات ارهابيه
قوانين الجهاز المخابرات هل يمنع مثل هذا
الامر ام انو في حالات هو
مقبول اذا كان امن الدوله في خطر قد يتم
التغاضي في كثير من الحالات عن بعض الامور
في سبيل تحقيق الامن والاستقرار لانه ايضا
ان يتم العبث بارواح الناس وممتلكاتهم
ويتم ويتم العبث ايضا بمقدرات الدول هذا
ينعكس سلبيا على على الدوله وعلى امنها
وعلى استقرارها وينعكس سيدا على اقتصاده
لذلك في كثير من الحالات لا بد للاجهزه
الامنيه ان تتعامل مع هذا الواقع وان تصل
الى هذه التنظيمات وان تمنعها وتسيطر
عليها قبل ان تقوم بتنفيذ ايه عمليات على
ارض الواقع نحن هنا في الاردن
دفعنا ثمنا كبيرا
لمواقفنا لسياساتنا من قبل هذه التنظيمات
الى الارهابيه التي استهدفتنا هنالك عمليه
الفنادق التي استهدفت الابرياء واستهدفت
الفنادق هنالك ايضا عمليات تستهدفت بعض
الدبلوماسيين هنالك بعض العمليات
الارهابيه ايضا كانت تستهدف قيادات وطنيه
وكانت تجتهدف بعض المنشات لكن يعني في
الجهاز يقض الجهاز المخابرات
ومتابعته لهذه التنظيمات الارهابيه
ولعناصرها كانت تمكن ان يتم ابطال الكثير
من العمليات والقاء القبض على كثير من
التنظيمات في الوقت المناسب وق ان تقوم
بتنفيذها هنالك لدينا يعني قبل فتره كان
هنالك مقتل استشهاد خمسه ثلاثه شباب في في
مخابرات البقعه وكان هنالك محاولات ايضا
من قبل بعض التنظيمات في قلعه الكرك لكن
تم السيطره عليها لذلك اقول انه هذه
التنظيمات الارهابيه تتعامل بدون اخلاق
وبدون ضمير وبدون مبرر الاجهزه الامن في
هذه الحاله لابد لها ان تتعامل مع هذه
التنظيمات لكي تبطل عملياتها وتبطل
تخطيطاتها وتلقي القبض على عناصرها
ويقدمهم الى الى القضاء حتى
لكن سعاده العميد انا هناك مثل ما تفضلت
ذكرت زرع عملاء من نفس جهاز اجهزه
الوكالات الاستخبارات وهناك التعاون مع
عملاء مزدوجين في هذه في قضيه العملاء
المزدوجين من داخل التنظيمات الاصوليه
الراديكاليه الى اي ماده مثلا اذا هو يعني
اظهر انه بيتعاون مع الجهاز المخابرات لكن
لديه جرائم سابقه شارك فيها وتورط فيها في
داخل التنظيم هل تعاوننا وتقديم المعلومات
سيعفيه عن المحاكمه والمساءله لا لا يعني
لا يمكن ان يتم الاطمئنان لمن قام ببعض
العمليات الارهابيه
الى حدوث
اعتداء على اشخاص او اعتداء على ممتلكات
او ايذاء او ضرر عام هذا يجب ان تطالوا
يجري العداله وان يشغل القضاء اما اذا كان
هذا الشخص قد تم تجنيده وتم زرعه في داخل
هذه التنظيمات لابد له ان يكون بتنفيذ
التعليمات التي يتلقاها من الجهاز من خلال
ضباط العمليات وضباط اداره المصادر الذين
يتابعون هؤلاء المصادرنهم ويديرونهم
ويحصلون على المعلومات منهم ويقومون ايضا
بتوجيههم لذلك الحقيقه اذا كان هذا العميل
كما اشرت
قد قام ببعض
الارهابيه لا يمكن ان يتم تجنيده مقابل
التغاضي عن هذه الاعمال الارهابيه يجب ان
تطالوا يدي العداله وبالتالي يقدم الى
القضاء والقضاء هو الفيصل في محاكمته من
خلال البيانات والادله التي يتم تقديمها
على غرار قصه الجاسوس احمد سمسم واللي تمت
محاكمته في اسبانيا او عدم الاعتراف
الاستخبارات الدنماركيه بتعاون معها
وحيث ان من الصعب ان يثبت العميل المزدوج
تعاون مع جهاز الاستخبارات فليس هناك يعني
ليس لدي شهاده راتب او عقد او ورقه تثبت
تعاونه ايش بيكون موقف العميل المزدوج في
هذه بعض العملاء يحاول احيانا ان يظهر
نفسه بان له علاقه بجهاز امني عندما يتم
عندما يقع او يتورط او يتم القاء القبض
عليه وانا اعتقد لو كان هنالك علاقه لهذا
العميل مع جهاز المخاب كما اشرت الى كان
هنالك تنسيق بين اسبانيا وبين الديان مارك
لانه اجهزه الامن في العالم تنسى مع بعضها
البعض وتتبادل للمعلومات ايضا في سبيل
متابعه هذه التنظيمات الارهابيه وعناصرها
وخططها وعملياتها لكن قد يكون
اللي اشرتي له حضرتك محمد سمسم او احمد
سمسم
قد يكون حاول ان يكون له علاقه لكي يتم
تغطيه نفسه وتبرئه وتبرير اعماله
الارهابيه وعندما تم القاء القبض عليه
يحاول ان ان يظهر نفسه بانه يعمل مع جهاز
الامن الدنماركي واعتقد لو كانه علاقه مع
جهاز الامن الدنماركي لا يمكن ان ينكر
جهاز الامن الدنماركي علاقته لكن اذا كان
حتى وان تذرع الجهاز المخابرات بانه لا
يستطيع ان يكشف عن اصول
المخابراتيه او عملائها
اي يعني يكون هنالك تنسيق سيدتي بين اجهزه
الامن مع بعضها البعض انت تتحدثين عن
دولتين اوروبا اوروبيتين وبالتالي اوروبا
منها وتتبادل المعلومات لو كان له علاقه
معين من هذه الاجهزه الاوروبيه لا تم
التنسيق بخصوصه واللي كان هنالك موقف
مشترك من الدول التي من الدول الاوروبيه
التي لديها تبادل للمعلومات ولديها متابعه
ولديها اهتمام بامن اوروبا كاملا كما هو
الحال بالنسبه
يعني نشوف القصص بنلاقي هناك تباين وتفاوت
ما بين تعامل في قضيه العملاء المزدوجين
العائدون من داعش
في هناك من تمت محاكمته وهناك من تم يعني
يتنقل بحريه بالذات ما تمت محاكمته تم
القاء القبض عليهم في دول اخرى يعني مثلا
محمد راشد تم القاء القبض عليه في تركيا
وتم من ثم ادعى او ذكر بانه هو متعاون مع
اجهزه مخابرات الكنديه احمد سمسم تم
الالقاء القبض عليه في اسبانيا وذكر بانه
تم انه عميل مزدوج لصالح وكاله
الاستخبارات الدنماركيه هنا ما بين هذه
الدول اشل حمايه التي يتلقاها العميل
المزدوج يعني الحقيقه لو كان هذا الشخص
عميل مزدوج مع اي جهاز من اجهزه الامن
التي اشرت اليها لكان هنالك مشترك بين هذه
الدول انا اقول ان اجهزه الامن تتابع
وتشارك وتتبادل للمعلومات فيما بينها في
سبيل كبح جماع هذه التنظيمات الارهابيه
ومتابعه عناصرها
بحسب تصريحات المسؤولين من اجهزه
المخابرات في الدنمارك وكندا بانهم لا يست
الكشف عن عملائهم خاصه ان العملاء
المزدوجين مرتبطين بعمليات اخرى ومرتبطين
باسماء اخرين في في داخل او في مناطق التي
من المفترض ان يكون يعني عملهم فيها
فهنا تصير يعني يصعب بحسب قول اجهزه
المخابرات التاكيد على ما يدعيه مثل هذه
العملاء المزدوجين يا ستي هم عندما يقوموا
بالتنسيق فيما بينهم لا يكشفون عن مصادر
معلوماته لكن يتم التنسيق بين هذه الاجهزه
الامنيه حمايه لمصادر وحمايه لمعلوماتهم
عندما
يكون هنالك عميل مزدوج وهذا العميل له
اهميه ولديه معلومات ويكون متصل باحد هذه
التنظيمات الارهابيه هذا يعتبر الحقيقه في
اوروبا بالذات يعني
شخص مهم بالنسبه لكل اجهزه الامن
الاوروبيه وعندما يتم التنسيق لا يتم
الاعلان عنه او او تفشل اسرار باعتبار ان
اجهزه الامن تنسق فيما بينها وتقوم ايضا
باتخاذ القرار المناسب حمايه لمصادرها
وحمايه لمعلوماتها خاصه اذا كان هذا الشخص
متصلا باحد هذه التنظيمات الارهابيه وكان
مجربا وعميلا مزدوجا لفتره زمنيه لابد من
الحفاظ على امن هنالك ما يسمى بامن
العملاء وامن المصادر خاصه كما قلت عندما
يكون له اتصال مباشر بتنظيم ارهابي وهذا
التنظيم يعمل لزعزعه الامن والاستقرار في
سواء كان في اوروبا او في غيرها
ولكن اذا لم يكن له علاقه وادعى ان له
علاقه هذا لا يلزم اي جهاز من اجهزه الامن
في العالم ان يتبنى هذا الارهابي او هذا
العميل الذي يدعي بان له علاقه مع احد الى
بسالك في موضوع
يتعلق في الاردن
طبعا الجهاز المخابرات الاردني معروف يعني
بالنسبه
لمعروف عالميا وايضا في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط انه احد اقوى اجهزه المخابرات لكن
كانت هناك قضيه يعني حسب ما يصفه البعض
بانه جيمس بوند المجاهدين هكذا يوصف هذه
الشخصيه من قبل انصار تنظيم القاعده وهو
يعني
وكان هو حقق انتصار على جهاز المخابرات
الامريكيه وايضا جهاز المخابرات الاردنيه
حيث نفذ عمليه او فجر نفسه في وسط عدد من
ضباط المخابرات الامريكيه والاردنيه قتل
سبعه ضباط امريكيين
وضابط اردني وهو ابو همام البلوي
بحدود العام 2009 وكان زرع هو كعميل مزدوج
في داخل تنظيم القاعده لكنه انقلب ونفذ
العمليه
في اجهزه الامن شو تحكيلها عن هذه هل
تعتبر هي هذه عمليه مثلا فاشله ام ان ان
هناك يعني
تجنيد العملاء المزدوجين هذا سلاح ذو حدين
يعني الحقيقه عندما يتم التعامل مع
التنظيمات الارهابيه ويتم التعامل مع ممن
باعوا انفسهم الى الشيطان ودون ان يكون هو
ليلك اي ضوابط اخلاقيه او دينيه او اي
دوافع او اي ضوابط وطنيه يجب ان يتم
التعامل معهم اولا بحذر وثانيا ان تتوقع
منهم ما هو غير متوقع يعني هذا الشخص
حضرتك اللي حكيتي عنه اللي كان يسمى ابو
دجانه الخرساني
وهذا اسمه الحركي وهو همام البلوي حمام
البلوي دكتور هذا طبيب
وتم تجنيده حسب معلوماتي وتم ارساله وكان
على اتصال مع تنظيم القاعده واخيرا وصل
وكان له اتصال مع ايمن الظواهري
وطبعا ايمن الظواهري كان احد الاشخاص
المطلوبين لوكاله المخابرات الامريكيه
وكان احد الاشخاص المهمين الذين تسال
وكاله بكافه الوسائل والسبل للوصول اليهم
من خلال من خلال تنسيق المعلومات طبعا
تم استدعائه الى قاعده خشت في افغانستان
وطبعا كان هنالك خطا كبير بانه لم يتم
تفتيشه من قبل من تم من استدعوه وحضر هو
وكان هو فجر نفسه قبل قبل هو فجر نفسه قبل
ما يصل على بعد امتار يعني كان بالامكان
انه يتم تفتي شو قبل ان يصل وقبل ان يكون
على مصروف من حيث لا يؤثر على امن الاشخاص
لكن هو فجر نفسه قبل قبل بضعه امتار وادى
الى مقتل سبعه من وكاله المخابرات
المركزيه الامريكيه وانت ايضا كان احد
الضباط الاردنيين ادى ايضا الى استشهاد
وبالتالي عندما تم استدعائه لانه كان لديه
معلومات عن ايمن الظواهري وكان قد تم قام
بتزويد
الاجهزه الامنيه بمعلومات عن ايمن
الظواهري تطابقت وموجود في سجلاته لدى
اجهزه الامن المصريه وبالتالي هو تمكن
خداع هذه الاجهزه وتمكن ايضا من ان يقوم
بتفجير نفسه مما ادى بالنتيجه الى مقتل
سبعه من وكاله المخابرات المركز الامريكيه
ومقتل الضابط الاردني الذي كان موجودا في
قاعده غوست في افغانستان
موضوع الانقلاب يعني
العميل المزدوج كيف الاجهزه المخابرات
تامل مثلا مصداقيه هذا العميل بانه هو ما
يلعب على الطرفين او يبيع المعلومات لاكثر
من وكاله استخبارات وحتى لتنظيمات اخرى
يعني هو اسمه عميل مزدوج وبالتالي يفترض
ان يكون التعامل معه بحذر وان يكون دائما
تحت المجهر والا يتم ايضا اعطاءه الامن
والامان الى ما لا نهايه يجب ان يكون
دائما تحت الاختبار وان يتم اختباره بين
كل فتره واخرى عقول وان يتم اختباره بين
كل فتره واخرى حتى يبقى
صادقا وان يتم اختبار معلوماته ايضا التي
يتم الحصول عليها وبالتالي
باستمرار لا بد ان يكون هنالك فحص لهؤلاء
العملاء المزدوجين وان يكون هناك متابعه
وان يكون هنالك اختبارات حتى من قبل جهاز
الامن لكي يختبر مصداقيته
ودقه معلوماته لذلك لا يوجد تامين او امان
مطلق يجب ان يكونوا دائما موضع شك وان
يكونوا دائما تحت المجهر وان يوضعوا دائما
تحت الفحص لكي يتم التاكد من
معلوماتهم ويتم التاكد ايضا من نواياهم
ويتم ومن ومن رغبته في التعامل والاستمرار
بالعمل يعني الان العميل المزدوج من جهادي
الى جاسوس في داخل تنظيمات الاصوليه
كالقاعده وتنظيم داعش وهي وغيرها من
التنظيمات جبهه النصره طالبان العديد من
هذه الجماعات كان يعني فيها عملاء مزدوجين
كيف يتحول او من هذه القناعه
يعني الاصوليه الى ان يصبح جاسوس ضد هذه
الجماعات يعني الحقيقه هو كما تعلمين انه
كثير
منظمه الارهابيه
تحاول اغراء الشباب وتحاول استغلال ظروفهم
واوضاعهم الماديه والاجتماعيه وتحاول ايضا
التي تغيب في كثير من الحالات عن بعض دول
المنطقه يعني كانت القضيه الفلسطينيه
وممارسات اسرائيل
وقيامها بالاعتداء على الشباب الفلسطيني
وابتلاع الارض الفلسطينيه وممارساتها كانت
احد اهم المصادر التي كانت تمول التنظيمات
الارهابيه بالعناصر لاحساس هؤلاء الشباب
الاحساس بالظلم واحساسهم ايضا بغياب
العداله لهذا من ناحيه من ناحيه ثانيه
يعني كثير من هؤلاء الاشخاص الذين يلتحقون
بهذه التنظيمات الاسلاميه
تغريهم الجنه ويغريهم ايضا ان هذه
التنظيمات تنظيمات جهاديه وتعمل
لتحرير الارض وتعمل ايضا
ضد المحتل وتعمل ضد اعداء لامه الحقيقه
هذا بمجمله يشكل بالنتيجه دوافع اساسيه
ورئيسيه تدفع هؤلاء الاشخاص الالتحاق بهذه
التنظيمات الارهابيه لكن عندما يلتحي كل
الارهابيه يجدون ان هذه التنظيمات
الارهابيه بعيده عن الاسلام وبعيده ايضا
عن القيم وبعيده عن الاخلاق وبان ما يتم
ممارسه داخل هذه التنظيمات هو اسوا مما
يتم ممارسته من قبل الانظمه خارجها
بالتالي يحدث حاله من الصراع
بنفسيات هؤلاء الاشخاص ويكونوا جاهزين
ايضا ل انفسهم لذلك يكون في حاله ضعف وقد
يتم تجنيده ويصبح امين مزدوج وبعضهم قد
يترك هذا التنظيم لكن يبقى موضع شكوى لانه
التحق مع هذه مع هذه التنظيمات وبالتالي
الحقيقه الامر يؤخذ على
مجموعه على مجموعه عوامل ومجموعه ضوابط لا
بد ان تؤخذ بعين الاعتبار سواء كان قبل
الالتحاق بالتنظيم او بعد التحاق بالتنظيم
طب بالنسبه للنساء ساده العميد
كعاملات
مزدوجات في داخل هذه التنظيمات من وحي
خبرتك في العمل الاستخباراتي الى اي مدى
ان ايضا يعتبر اصول مهمه في داخل هذه
التنظيمات يعني الان لم يعد هنالك فرق بين
الرجل والمراه
الهدف او العميل الذي يستطيع ان يصل الى
المعلومات ويصل الى الهدف بغض النظر عن
الجنس هو هدف محت
اذكر حضرتك بعمليه الفنادق ساجد الريشاوي
التنظيم الارهابي الذي هاجم الفنادق وتم
اعتقاله وبالتالي تم الحكم عليها بالاعدام
وبالتالي حتى النساء قد يكون هنالك بعض
المواقف لا تصلح لها الا النساء والنساء
قادرات على ان يحقق ويصل اليها ويحصل على
المعلومات في بعض الحالات اكثر من الرجال
لذلك العمليه ليست مختصه او مرتبطه بالجنس
او بالرجل او بالمراه بقدر ما ترتبط
بنوعيه الهدف وكيفيه الوصول الى المعلومه
وتحقيق الهدف
وتحقيق الهدف الذي يريد الجهاز الذي
يتعامل مع الحاله التي نتحدث عنه طيب ساده
العميد بسالك اذا تخصنا من يعني من وحي
تجربتك في العمل المخابرات في جهاز
المخابرات الاردني ودي لو تخصنا بقصه او
يعني قصه عميل مزدوج استطاع استطاعت اجهزه
الامن الاردنيه تجنيده في داخل تنظيم
القاعده او تنظيم داعش وساهم في الوصول
الى قيادي مهم
وتحييد هذا القياده يعني الحقيقه انا بدي
اذكر حضرتك بعد عمليه الفنادق
لاختصاص الذين كانوا قد خططوا لعمليه
الفنادق كانوا موجودين بالعراق
الاجهزه الامنيه الاردنيه من ان تصل الى
العراق الشقيق بالتنسيق مع العراق وان
تقوم باعتقال هؤلاء الاشخاص الذين كان لهم
علاقه بعمليه الفنادق وان تحضرهم الى
الاردن وتقدمهم وتم تقديمهم وتم محاكم هذه
من الناحيه الثانيه يعني الاردن ايضا قبل
تنظيم القاعده وقبل تنظيم
قبل هذه التنظيمات الارهابيه كان هنالك
تنظيمات اخرى تعمل اريد ان اعود بالذاكره
الى ما يسمى بتنظيم ابو نضال تنظيم
تنظيم ابو نضال تنظيم ارهابي وكان يستهدف
كل الدول العربيه ومن خلال هذا التنظيم تم
تجنيد عدد كبير من القيادات بداخل هذا
التنظيم وكانت كل مصادر سلاحه وعملياته
وكل الاموال التي تخرج من هذا التنظيم
باتجاه الدول العربيه كان يتم السيطره
عليها والتنسيق بين الدول العربيه بين
الاردن وبين هذه الدول العربيه التي كان
يستهدفها التنظيم ويتم افشال الكثير من
هذه العمليات في الحقيقه هذه عمليات تتكرر
يوميا وليست حالي فريده او حاله واحده طب
اسمح لي اختم بهذا السؤال احنا بنشوف
عناصر بنشوف تنظيم القاعدات تنظيم داعش
كثير يعني لديه اصدارات حتى سلسله من
الاجزاء بعنوان حصاد الجواسيس
يعني
نشاهد تنفيذ الاعدامات بعناصر من مقاتليه
او وقياديه ايضا حتى ايضا ابتكروا اجهزه
استخبارات في داخل هذه التنظيمات نفسها
يعني لمراقبه ومتابعه عناصرها وقياديها هل
تشوف ان هذه فوبيا باتت لدى هذه التنظيمات
ام انها بالفعل الاصطياد قيادات
الصف الاول من هذه التنظيمات هو من فعل
العملاء المزدوجين يعني قدره الاجهزه
ووكالات الاستخبارات على اختراق قلب هذه
التنظيمات يعني هذه التنظيمات سيدتي
كالنار تاكل بعضها البعض
وايضا هنالك دور لاجهزه الامن ايضا في
كثير من الحالات ان تحدث بعض الفتنه وبعض
وايهام قيادات التنظيم لبعض العناصر الذين
يقومون ببعض العمليات
لتسليط الضوء عليهم ومحاوله التشكيك
بمواقفهم وبالتالي يقوم التنظيم حول
التصفيه بعض الاشخاص الذين يشك بولاهم او
يشك بانتماهم ولا يعملون لمصلحته هذه
ناحيه الناحيه عفوا الناحيه الثانيه ايضا
يعني الاجهزه الامن معنيه ان تتابع هذه
التنظيمات ومعنيه ايضا ان تحدث حاله من
الارباك وحاله ايضا من الشكوك بداخل هذه
التنظيمات لكي لا تقع هذه التنظيمات تشير
بالعمل بضد الدول وضد منها وضده استقرارها
ولكي يتم ايضا تشكيكه بانفسها وتشكيك
بعناصرها وبقياداتها يعطيك الف عافيه
سعاده العميد وشكره لك معنا في حلقتنا
واسمح لي ان اختم هنا في مارس 2019 سقطت
اخر قطعه من معاقل تنظيم داعش في بلده
باغوز السوريه وبه اقفل فصل دوله داعش
وفتح فصل ما بعدها فصل العملاء المزدوجين
وعالم الاستخبارات والمقاتلين المتجولين
في الدول الغربيه وكل الدهاليز السريه
والغبار المتطاير الذي اعقب سقوط بنيان
داعش فهل تتسع الدراما العربيه وغير
العربيه لكل هذه التفاصيل الغزيره
والمعقده هذا جماعات وانا هدى الصالح
[موسيقى]